- This circular painting
by Robert Delaunay
is one of many that takes advantage
and really responds to the science
of the beginning of the 20th century
and thinking about the heavens,
thinking about the movements
of the sun, the moon,
the planets as a kind of model
for what abstract painting could be.
You may note Delaunay
dates the picture 1912.
We now know, of course,
that it was painted in 1913.
There was such a kind
of rat-a-tat-tat barrage
of new ideas that
artists had a great stake
in being the first one
to do what they did.
In this case, something from 1913
is stated to have been from 1912.
It's an era of invention.
It's an era of discovery.
It's not an era of doing
what other people do.
It's an era of doing what you're
doing before anybody else.
Delaunay was very
interested in color theory,
and there were very complicated,
conflicting theorists
about complementary colors,
about primaries and secondaries,
and paintings like this one
are where he tested out those theories,
the ways in which subtleties of shades
actually bloom into new colors,
depending on the way the
artist combines them.
This painting has in its
title the word simultaneous,
an idea of movement, an
idea of passing of time.
You're actually not
seeing something still,
because there are light
waves, there are sound waves,
there are particles.
Artists at this time
were very conscious of
the many, many new aspects
of scientific thought
that were upending the idea of the world,
of space and of time as
a constant, stable given.
They wanted to translate
that into their paintings,
and Delaunay did that into this painting
and all of his paintings.